and welcome to hannity this is a fox
news alert tonight amid stiff resistance
the russian army is attempting to
encircle ukraine's capital city of kiev
inch by inch and tonight it does appear
they are making progress albeit slow
progress now president zielinski says
that russia can only take the city if it
raises keeve to the ground but that is
exactly probably what putin is planning
this is now an extraordinarily dangerous
time for ukraine and the entire world
and to make things dramatically worse
the world does not have a strong and a
decisive us president or us vice
president just take a look at your
screen this is drone footage from
southern ukraine where multiple cities
are being utterly destroyed by
indiscriminate russian artillery and
bombing attacks in what is being
described as a medieval siege there is
no power there is no food there are no
medical supplies and just miles and
miles of smoldering apartment complexes
thousands of innocent men women and
children now dead including this
pregnant woman and her unborn baby now
putin's plan to quickly capture ukraine
and install a puppet regime didn't work
well and now a very angry vladimir with
his back against the wall and the world
watching is hell-bent on blowing up
everything and everyone in his path and
that includes yep innocent women and
children
us
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
now to their credit the ukrainian people
they are fighting hard for their country
but they are severely outmatched
outmanned and outgunned and as bad as it
is now all indications tonight are
things will deteriorate quickly
very quickly on the ground ukraine they
need weapons ammunition anti-aircraft
systems the two dozen mig-29 fighter
jets that poland offered them that
proposal joe biden personally vetoed and
blocked joe is worried that the deal
would upset and anger putin and russia
it shows nothing but weakness it reveals
how easily joe is intimidated by
vladimir putin maybe he should be
reminding him of the weaponry we have as
we all know weakness invites aggression
just look at what happened over the
weekend iran nearly destroyed our u.s
consulate building in iraq with a
ballistic missile attack america needs
to be asking tonight of their president
joe what are you going to do
now pathetically it looks like he may be
handing over billions in frozen iranian
assets while negotiating to import oil
from the number one state sponsor of
terror and make iran and the muellers of
iran rich again and the worst part is as
of now it is russia and china they are
the ones brokering this deal with the
mullis and because joe biden is so
desperate for a nuclear deal with iran
even worse than the first one with obama
and biden and the muellers in iran
they're pretending this attack oh it's
nothing to worry about really the
administration claiming the u.s wasn't
even the real target uh that i call out
is total adam schiff i believe that's a
lie joe biden is the modern-day neville
chamberlain iran was targeting israel
they claimed so no reason to be upset
our number one ally in the middle east
no big deal just iran being iran really
the administration claims the u.s wasn't
even the real target again so now it's
oh no reason be upset meanwhile as bad
as all of this is and it's bad china is
now openly threatening quote the worst
consequences for any country that
supports taiwan's military here's a
problem we currently have a us military
presence right there in taiwan and we
also equip taiwan with weapons and
training so again we asked joe biden
what are you going to do about this
overt threat joe are you going to do
anything anywhere at all now china is
reportedly ready and willing to ship
weapons and other aid to russia to help
resupply putin's bloody invasion of
ukraine so it's kind of official now joe
we've been telling you it's happening
and occurring for some time
china russia iran they're all
threatening the us and the world at the
same time and joe biden is doing
absolutely nothing to counter all of
this aggression on the world stage and
his pathetic feckless weakness it is
causing all of this there is no
president in our lifetime weaker than
joe biden now with the world crumbling
around him after major failures at home
and abroad joe of course he's not taking
any responsibility he's not owning up to
any of his screw-ups and he's not
changing course which is worse instead
joe oh i believe everything i screw up
is vladimir putin's fault he is lying to
you the american people take a look you
decide second big reason for inflation
is vladimir putin
and gas prices not a joke
make no mistake
the current spike in gas price is
largely the fault of vladimir putin
it has nothing to do with the american
rescue plan
what was simply embarrassing and
humiliating is now beyond dangerous joe
biden's poll numbers are in the tank the
american people see that he's lying no
one respects him no one believes him and
maybe it's time that joe biden kamala
harris gensake stop lying to you the
american people putin is not to blame
for the record high gas prices joe's
economic and energy policies are putin
didn't block the keystone xl pipeline he
didn't ban exploration and auctions on
federal lands now the keystone xl
pipeline for example would have been
finished now according to the premier of
alberta and canada and we'd have 900 000
barrels of canadian oil flowing through
that pipeline into the u.s every single
day that oil we could use now that was
joe biden and the new green deal
socialist democrats they stopped this
putin didn't spend trillions in cause
america's 40-year record high of
inflation and joe stop lying putin
didn't cause that because long before
putin invaded ukraine we had month after
month after month 40-year high after
40-year high inflation that was you joe
biden and just like putin didn't abandon
our fellow americans in afghanistan in
case you're counting like we are it is
day 212. joe biden
did that not vladimir putin putin did
not pull out of the country the the most
dangerous and chaotic way possible and
wait till the very end to do it leading
to the deaths of 13 u.s servicemen and
women abandoning our fellow americans
green card holders our allies own 80
some odd billion dollars worth of
military equipment that was all joe
biden just like joe biden ran out of
cova tests and monoclonal antibodies
over christmas unforgivable inexcusable
just like joe gave up energy
independence and gave up america being
the net exporter of energy just like joe
biden's disaster at the southern border
you're going to blame putin for that too
joe
stop blaming putin joey you have created
one preventable disaster after another
let's be clear putin is an evil
murdering thug this is a a
regime that is looking for as much
territory as they can get but all of
america's problems did not originate 5
000 miles away in moscow they're your
policies don't expect joe biden to ever
right the ship or take responsibility
that would mean he'd have to admit that
well donald trump was right on the
border right on energy right on
afghanistan right on the economy but
that's never going to happen biden has
never been particularly competent but
now he is also weak frail and a
cognitive mess i'm not even sure he
knows today's monday or what day of the
week is on any given day and on friday
before jetting off for his weekend of
ice cream at camp david for some rest
and relaxation biden delivered this
truly
even for him bizarre speech take a look
the moment it opens it will be disbanded
you hear me
it will blow up
for mom to get her kid on the internet
to be able to do their homework has to
pull into mcdonald's parking lot
i mean for real
as it was happening
this law is going to put an end to all
that
going to put people in a much different
position to be able to determine their
own
their own judgments about when to sell
their cattle
when they should i'm just
going to change things
i'm on track to be the first president
of history to lower the deficit by over
one trillion dollars in one year
so i'm sick of this stuff
really okay mcdonald's for internet and
selling cattle and this guy doesn't have
a clue here's a serious question every
american needs to ask tonight do you
feel safe and secure with that man as
your president at the helm of your
country do you really think he has the
mental strength and stamina and acuity
to make sound decisions does he even
have the courage to do what is obviously
right for you we the american people and
while america's president is struggling
every day mightily there are so many
people all over the world they are now
risking it all to do what is right in
russia for example look at this employee
of a tv channel rushed onto the set
during a live propaganda broadcast
with a sign that reached stop the war no
to war she will probably be thrown in
prison and faces a 15-year russian
prison sentence let this be an important
reminder never take your freedoms for
granted as ronald reagan said freedom is
but one generation away from extinction
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else